today's show is sponsored by druids
fluids for all your holy water needs
this is the technical difficulties we
are playing citation needed I have an
almost randomly selected article for
everybody's favorite reliable source of
knowledge Wikipedia and these folks
can't see it every fact they get right
gets them a point and a ding and the
special prize for particularly good
answers which is rather and today we are
talking about possible don't what though
can you use that in a sentence for
football
no are we talking a sport though not
even close is it a type of ball is it
roughly spherical yeah it is roughly
spherical but no is it a seed or fruit
or pizza food stuff I'll give you a
crucible is a foodstuff that yes is it
deep-fried oh no what it's not from
these shores then is it made of pieces
of other things I would itself though
isn't it I every foodstuff let's go
let's go eating pure sodium yum yum yum
that's pretty paid pretty much made of
pieces of other things yes like you get
like a fish cake or you get a fish okay
I know it's a it's made it's made of
other ingredients is it of Africa
it's Dutch Dutch Josh it's a possible
the servo bus of all the Dutch people
are gonna is it he'll be cold no not
even close completely the other end of
this very fact
so it's wrong if you had a spectrum no
in terms of taste from pickle
actually alright and so this sweet then
yes right it's a treat as a cake or
something like that yeah
just rightly and it's roughly spherical
truffled I'm done all I'm doing is it a
sweet cake based edom you know what yet
ops that's actually that's close enough
I'm gonna give you it's better you know
that size profiterole ah
Yahweh's oversized professional how
oversized are the size of your head
little cream out the inside is only a
tip to remain like a helmet
of the Dutch space program with enjoy a
profiterole around the head of a man in
the lower atmosphere
okay the grieve is keeping me fed I have
eaten it's all I have to fight Felicia
parish but I'm glad we finally washed up
on the nationality we're going to insult
the bishop never think about you can
have the chocolate slices like a visor
couldn't you because if further
hemisphere you go the cold is gonna get
the most solid she's gonna be all right
it won't survive reentry very well if
it's chocolate you know you've got the
cream for insulation yeah not a phrase
I've said before haha again as it gets
yeah they are a point these Dutch people
with their professor on space program
you could because you could fit them
inside a giant Twinkie or Barney bear or
something as the spacesuit so so
possible what's the name of this first
space capsule yes yes absolutely the
same way the first French spaceship was
called profiterole that's it no no no
retro you know that call it bug a bug
when okay prepare Isles a small little
talking one that's as big as a spear so
I see gel one it's about five inches a
little bit bigger than my Maha there is
a bit of culinary advice in this article
what's the best way to avoid spillage
when eating a possible sit on it eat it
whole ride it puncture it suck out it's
delicious in it and then consume the
outside yes
squeeze it like a spot haha no no no
Enterprise with a spoon the best way to
avoid spillage from your booster bottle
is the question you're on yeah this is
yes sir these are special receptacle for
this no those are balls sphere
perimeters I don't like possible
spillage who does another fer vanish
won't touch it when it did it turn it
upside down well actually says it the
best way to avoid sponges by eating the
pastry upside down I don't know what
that means the pastry or the person or
the person that's my kind of dessert the
kind is is that you have to be strapped
down for that's the taste sensation I'm
looking for
all right we've got a three-person
slingshot and a bustle ah ah oh yes what
would it feel like to be hit by a
five-inch wide professor all its people
based on the juggling ball I got hit
with it'll be bloody pain I got hit by a
water balloon in the face oh you're the
real big I still got the animated gif of
that somewhere else if I was eating
about thank you for the cream do what it
would it would it go
you know what it'd be like not you've
aspirate but you know the action when it
melt and I like I like to sing that it
turned on you toning it go solid you
just knocked unconscious I can believe
that is it our water balloon Christ if
you did it with a custard film on it
what would wall us custard is
non-newtonian only if it's not sugary
you put sugar in you actually chosen
just like right right so yeah after hang
on we've discovered a new weapon chaps
you if you could put it on the barrel of
a Navy frigate I come cuz I've seen an
episode of Dad's Army where they fire
onions at people and they look like it
hurt so I'm actually accurate ballistics
steel and depleted uranium custard
filling but I'm not saying it's used for
destruction I'm saying issues for shock
and awe haha splatting are really with
me there is a bigger version of the
possible just draggers burger SuperBot
shop ah well you see that's pretty close
I don't want I don't actually want the
the Dutch word for it but if you could
tell me what it's called when you
translate it to English the mega bar the
very big profiterole you know I'm gonna
give you both points it's giant ball
what I love is that in the see also
section of this page is just list of
pastries Oh see how many we can get by
round names and pastries Matt
a Danish pastry point Gary cream horn oh
good long hard to point it
Shubin I try to spell that I say Joey
there and it did it all so that I'll
give you a point it's under Eclair but
yes point it Claire point Viennese world
good lord no it's on the list it's not
pastry us biscuit the cavity there I
also like in here we have cronut is
already amazing to Wikipedia oh come on
I don't I don't yeah well it's a
croissant and a donut
he said donut made of cotton pastry
bread dough but isn't that just a
croissant with the whole Chuck tell them
but no it's deep fryers and a bait you
know those yum Yum's they having greg's
oh it's the yum yum it's one of them
yeah I was it's made with a croissant
dough so it's buttery err and add more
layers and such and causes more
flakiness down the front of a shirt of a
morning I've never thought oh I don't
know whether I want a croissant or a
doughnut now so I want one of the other
I don't get the whole American breakfast
thing having like doughnuts and
something that sweet in that sugary you
need right sickles
I don't okay I'm right she calls with a
little space nice man
yeah good grief they still make that I
don't think they do I have not snow ice
cores for a long time on the other hand
if we do find some what I'm having them
tomorrow according to everyone's
favorite unreliable source of knowledge
yes they still sell them yes okay they
don't put in the variety packs anymore
though I saw her I could have a whole
box yes I was sitting nah no tell you
about you you remember the box of Coco
Pops I brought last time we did this
a.m. in two days I think rice box
arrives causing one sittings on Fistful
of rye sickles that's just for a few
Raisa calls no we're going to bad
captain Rick
yes all these it's Coco - monkey just
sat with a hat down over his eyes at the
side just throwing a knife up and ere we
say ah turning the Tigers this Sheriff
yeah the entire section the cronut
article on controversy um don't tell me
how much they were selling for because
the original Crona is trademarked - one
bakery they were selling them for $5 how
much was scalpers selling them for later
in the day I cut well they last that
long are they being a French best bread
product that gone off within about an
hour as we previously yes I'm gonna say
it $20 $20 you know I'm even though it's
a terrible way of doing I'm gonna do
Price is Right rules here ah closest
without going over we have the little
yodeling man went up a hill here no $20
yeah Chris 20 dollars and one cent oh
nine nine dollars $100 you've worked for
it for a bloody pastry but it was one of
those things where the the public get a
fixation on it and it starts no it's
basically Bitcoin in pastry for you can
almost get a flight except it lasts
longer hey Danny Kelly one could be some
of the alternate names that people have
called the cronut just to get around the
tone on fatty wheel flaky death the fat
will Pat well no Dawson Dawson
he's going to selling a doesn't also on
the list of pastries we have something
called nun's puffs Brannon I feel this
is shopper please make another sequitur
oh not exactly did that took me like
three so that was that was good
Oh around any moment I've had that joke
on a list for years and that is the
first time I be able to use it are you
looking because you were really
nonchalant on your delivery
that's not that hard to have it you want
to get into now are you whimpering in a
corner it's listed as nuns puffs that is
a euphemism
can you read about this recently it's
recalled are they those little round
buns with icing in a cherry on that's
not the cherry they're basically like
kind of light dessert pastry they're the
ones that have the name nuns farts point
and they're called nuns farts and they
are just a ball of pastry that is very
very light with a cream filling in them
so profiteroles underling
could have a nun sparklies of course
sister Levi boundless but you sell it on
light you 400 see ya in a jar you know
on that note I think Matt you got most
part I mean I'll be honest I'm not
counting uh I certainly didn't get any
so it wasn't me this time Matt
congratulations you and a copy of the
game where you have to get executives of
a disgraced bank to jump through pipes
and defeat Bowser super Lehman Brothers
oh it's alright enough times faster
until next time that's been my gray
that's been Gary Brannen didn't say
that's gone not bad everybody we've been
working together for while long now
all yours no bet that was Gary Brannen
and that's Chris Joel bye
kiss me I was a good pastry based
episode though thanks for watching if
you've got this far then hopefully you
liked the show leave us a comment if you
do the feedback we get from you all is
really welcome
or better yet tell some other folks
about us and don't forget there are
audio episodes of our reverse trivia
podcast at Tech disco UK